in your your book on investing and it's
I I think what you just said about going
to the Young Generation where it goes
and everything
um you know a lot of people and I was
curious about it is is kind of the
forecast on you follow government and
this is a nonpartisan thing also
security Medicare and the entitlement
how to structurally we have to change as
a nation so that we can we can serve all
that because this is this this mass of
people that are retiring yes that that
deserve to get what they paid for
literally out of their tax well remember
we have a pay-as-you-go system which
means we have no money
um so when you pay your Social Security
every week that's going to pay you know
you know somebody else's grandmother or
something because there's no real money
there's no lock box there's no trust
fund
when people when Social Security was set
up in 1933 the average life expectancy
in the United States was 65. when could
you collect your Social Security at 65.
so that not that many people were living
we live in the Catholic now it's like 82
83. so you now people are living for a
long time and you're collecting Social
Security we don't have enough money to
to be able to keep paying it right now
the budget the entitlement part of the
budget is with defense spending
entitlements and interest it's roughly
80 percent of the budget 80 85 percent
of budget it's only about 15 is left for
everything else so at some point you're
going to have to do one of three things
you either cut their the the benefits
you increase taxes or you basically have
to increase the amount of money that
you're going to borrow you're going to
borrow more money or you further extend
when they can get the social security
business yeah you can do that too but
you're gonna have to borrow more money
we have 31 trillion dollars of debt now
31 trillion that's you know that's not
all the commitments though that's just
the debt that we that's the debt yeah
that's the debt and that's the money
we've already borrowed the future
commitments are staggering but we have a
higher percentage of debt uh to GDP than
any country in the world product except
maybe Italy which is not a great role
model no it's not so uh so right now the
only way you're going to solve this
problem is you've got to cut benefits
you could extend the age which is a way
of cutting benefits you have to
um you have to increase taxes or you
just borrow keep borrowing more money
there's no other way around it
you have a follow-up on that because for
me you know what I look at sometimes I'm
like okay you know the the American
economy is this it's strong we're this
we're that
I mean how the hell do we eventually
right off the debt like what happens
when the interest rates are going up
right now and what if we can make the
payments because because the you know to
Japan or China one of them we owe 1.1
trillion which I think is Japan China I
think we own oh one trillion these are
not small interest payments that we have
to make what happens when we default on
those things when well hopefully we
never default but when when the interest
rate is essentially zero yeah you can
borrow a lot of money and so the federal
government was paying maybe three
percent of the budget for interest
now the interest rates are going up
we're paying six and seven percent of
the budget for interest because if rates
are going up 31 trillion dollars that's
a lot of money and we only had 15 to
play with of the remaining budget that's
about it how long is that sustainable
though
there's only one way out of it it's you
inflate your way out of the economy out
of it that's the only way out because
we're not going to default that's
unrealistic yeah we're not going to
increase taxes that's very hard to do we
can do it occasionally it's not easy to
cut spending where you're going to cut
it so you're not going to go to the IMF
for a bailout so in the end you're going
to inflate your way out of it that's the
only way out of it you're not going to
default
to have a follow-up question for you
know for the common Joe out there it's
it's watching this podcast you know the
the Fidelity came out the report that
said the average savings of baby boomers
today is 138 000 for retirement Gen X 98
000 Millennials 63 000 gen Z 37 000. in
your opinion is the typical person
attempting to save for a retirement are
they getting crushed right now in the
future or do they have to do something
like you know we have a very low savings
rate in this country compared to other
countries very low savings rate we have
a consumer economy we encourage people
to buy things to help people don't save
them much if you want to reduce our
trade deficit tell people to to save
more but we don't do that it's just
because it's thought to be uh you know
difficult to get people to save more
that's a real problem and a lot of
people in this country are living
paycheck to paycheck a very high
percentage or increasingly living
paycheck to paycheck there are a lot of
problems in there in the lower part of
the economic strata for sure and it's
not changing overnight what's your
what's your solution what's your
suggestion for the demographic that's
the demographic we all come from here at
this table I I if I had the solution I
would be in Iowa New Hampshire I don't
have the solution
um I I I don't know if I had the
solution I would have done something
about it there's no easy way out of it
no easy way out and I don't think
anybody has an easy way out so what all
the craziness taking place I believe
future looks bright if you believe
future looks bright get your latest
Future looks bright hat of valuetainment
it says future looks right here future
looks bright here we got them in white
we got them in Black we got them in red
are black on black sold out these are
about to sell out if you haven't ordered
one yet we had a person in Michigan but
one then he bought three then when those
three people wore it in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks spread toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]